Wednesday Adams is a true genius who is
good at pretty much everything from
playing the cello to fencing to solving
Mysteries and on and on and on listen to
how intense a typical Day filming
Wednesday was she had to get to set
several hours early to make sure that
iconic Wednesday Adam's look was perfect
then they shot for like 14 hours and
these are intense episodes too she had
to do all that with an added challenge
that few other actors have ever faced
she wasn't allowed to Blink yeah Jenna
impressed Tim Burton by limiting her
blinks so much that he encouraged her to
pretty much stop blinking altogether the
secret strategy Jenna used during her
Wednesday shoots was that any time it
felt like she needed to Blink she just
didn't blink she had lessons set up for
her at home sometimes there would be
Zoom calls that ran her through a
fencing lesson some fight choreography
or any of the other 8 000 things she had
to do for the show